you know I think I've changed my mind I
think that investing is [__] stupid
okay let's jump right in people been
craving a brainstorm and we're gonna
give them a brainstorm can I tell you
one thing really quick before we get to
the brainstorm yeah let's do it okay so
I'm gonna go buy a car in about three
hours and I'm gonna live starting August
I'm gonna live in a new city each month
for 12 months and it's gonna be I'm
looking for a list of happiest cities so
okay how about let me know well I've
seen that once before and I think it was
like you're talking about us only right
I think like Switzerland or Sweden is
number one or something yeah I would go
to Canada I want to go to Mexico City
because I love it but the corona thing I
don't think is under control there at
least to drive there I wouldn't to drive
through those cities in order to get
there so where are you starting do you
know number one I think it's gonna be
Provo is it called Provo or Provost
what's called probably Utah Utah the
Mormons like are definitely the happiest
so I'm gonna go and hang out with them
and and then I don't know I got a plan
it okay well I think that's good you
should figure it out as you go and
somebody somebody tweeted this as a
reply because I think you mentioned this
maybe on the last one and they were like
dude you must have the coolest wife
who's just dad to do all this stuff
they're like you think we need to get
her on the pod so I have two questions
for you about that eh what's her
reaction to your you know life plans
like this like crazy life plans is she
does she feed into them does she pull
you back a little bit and say hey here's
what's a little more realistic is she
just down for whatever like what's her
what's her down yeah she's a little more
conservative than I am but she's down
but does this seem like a crazy idea
this doesn't seem like a crazy idea at
all I don't think it's crazy necessarily
but it's an orthodox right like most
people don't do this let's say it's
unusual I don't think it's crazy I think
it's good here why I think this is weird
if I told my wife if I said well now we
have a baby so that's probably his place
when you were childless yeah yeah I if I
had said hey I want to move every month
to a different City she would have been
like
why are we doing all this like no let's
not do that like okay you wanna go on
vacation let's go on vacation I think
that would have been a reaction no we're
really pushed for it if I was like I
need this she would have done it but it
helps that I don't have kids and we know
that we're gonna have Sara's 27 so we're
gonna have kids in three years so we're
definitely like let's just party right
yeah that's good
Sonny's a year older than me and so for
day one it's been like yo buddy I'm on
the clock let's do this okay so that's
one thing that's one question and then
the second question is does she listen
to the podcast yeah yeah she does so
alright nice that would be interesting
to have wives come on because they have
to deal like how do they handle like
Sarah it's a handful for her to work
with me for sure like because I'm so
crazy we should do a crazy happy hour
episode one time right night happy hour
episode not crazy like I want to do a
wild [__] all the time but emotionally
I'm just like [__] nuts I think a lot
of people who create stuff are so she
does have to put up with [__] she's
patient so it's good my wife is goes
crazy on the miner and is down for the
major and what I mean by that is like if
I if I suggest something that's a minor
change or inconvenience or or setback
she overreacts and then if I'm like like
she was pregnant and I was like I'm
gonna quit my job we're gonna have no
healthcare I'm gonna go do this crazy
thing it's super high risk high reward
and she was like okay yeah I believe in
you and so like on the major things
she's like the switch flips in her head
and she's like okay I gotta be super
resilient now wait did you just reveal
something no this was before oh and when
she was writing it before before we had
a baby cuz I was like look I'm gonna
sell this company or I'm gonna end the
company but one of two ways we're not
gonna continue this as is like I'm gonna
go for the sale hard for 30 days which
is too short and if we if we get a term
sheet we get a term sheet if we don't
get a term sheet I actually want to just
go do something else that I think has
higher upside and that'll mean no salary
no healthcare no nothing and if this
doesn't work out well and you moved
I mean you I feel like you bought a
house and moved on a whim yeah I did
that too okay let's jump it let's do
some of these topics what do you got
what do you wanna start okay let's start
with duck duck
okay I've I was on the James Altucher
podcast
James was here with us a few weeks ago
James is like a like a dork nerdy guy I
say this would love I like him a lot
he's like a nerdy guy libertarian guy
libertarian audience and I can't decide
if this whole privacy stuff that we're
talking about so hey calm female service
launched a few days ago a few weeks ago
a week ago yeah its premise is like
we're one of its many promises it's on
privacy okay and so I'm really into this
privacy thing the founder of Pandora
told me that he is seeing his customers
who are middle America people actually
care about privacy and when I was on my
trip I saw DuckDuckGo billboards
everywhere for those who don't know duck
taco it's a google competitor it's a
search engine and they it's all based on
they don't track you which like [__]
ruins the business model have no idea
how they make money
but no no it doesn't so their thing was
like it's not no ads so they still do
search ads but they're like look when
you search for you said you're gonna go
buy a new car when you go search for you
know Mercedes versus BMW or whatever
you're gonna search for they'll serve
you an ad they just don't need to know
that you're sampar that you live in this
place that you have life you know they
don't need the personal data for the ads
to still be effective because search is
high intent they know what you're
looking for so they can serve you of
relevant ad and their insight was the
slight drop off you get by not
personalizing is not so bad if that can
become your value proposition that hey
we're not using personal information to
serve these ads okay so I just sent you
their traffic DuckDuckGo comm slash
traffic so here's my question to you
first of all and we're looking at a
hockey stick we're looking at anomalous
and 10 2010 they're at you know this is
this is queries per dare this is average
yeah so they average 62 million queries
per day I have no idea I mean what do
you think Google's queries per day
probably like like 5 billion I mean a
brief see if you can find let's see if
you can find Google's careers today so
we could put this so 3.5 billion off ok
ok yes corrine Google or duck duck goes
at 50 50 60 million a day
so the
I don't even know what's that like 3%
the size anyway DuckDuckGo what do you
think about that I personally love this
and what I want to know from you is do
you like deco and do you also think this
privacy thing like building products
where the main feature or values in like
or like the main thing the brain stands
for is privacy do you think that's gonna
be it
I think it's a hit I used to think the
opposite I used to be of the camp that
was like look people don't give a [__]
like if you just say yeah sure in theory
people want privacy if you offer no
privacy or privacy but when it comes
down to products they're like oh this is
a free good thing and I have to give up
all my data all right here you go and so
I used to think that people in practice
were willing to easily trade privacy and
I think that's still true on the whole
oh yes where is the pendulum swinging
and so I think the pendulum is swinging
more towards people caring about privacy
because every these things stack up
right so as you you know the more
paranoid you get the less lack of trust
you have in the system and of the of the
big companies it doesn't matter you
don't have to know which one is the
straw that breaks the camel's back maybe
it's the fake new stuff on Facebook
maybe it's when your information gets
breached for the 35th time and you get
an email saying hey sorry your personal
if I might've been leaked but you don't
know where it is but these things just
keep happening and to the point where I
believe people care more than they did
before and they'll continue to care more
that's number one number two you have to
do it on a global product like a product
everybody uses cuz it's still a niche
audience all right like you said Google
is about 50 times the search query size
then induct echo up so like 50 to one
and so you need a product that's used by
pretty much everybody for that those
ones to add up and be a big enough
market for you so I wouldn't do it on
some niche products like oh you do you
know some niche mailing you know
MailChimp software thing cool I'm gonna
make a privacy focused version it's like
no that's that's an issue of a niche
well if it's about ego stream it works
like hey calm
I caught hey calm Global write emails
everybody yes it is global but like
you don't need that many users to build
a billion-dollar company totally what
I'm - that's was saying though you need
you're only gonna get the sort of 2%
let's say that value privacy enough to
make a change and so you know like
superhuman did the same thing email such
a huge market cool we'll go get the 1%
2% who are willing to pay 30 bucks a
month for a free for instead of free
email I think this is anything happening
here I pray you how old are you 27
you're a little old for this question
the zoom ray just five years ago no it's
a generational thing I want to know do
the 22 year olds give a [__] about this
because the way that the Zoomers the way
that they live and think is really [__]
about getting coronaviruses the privacy
of their data they don't care about
their body they're a pretty
conscientious group of people i think i
don't know i would i want to know how
they think
but that was my question okay so here's
another private here's another
opportunity for privacy that I'm
interested in do you know that when you
go to Safeway so in California we have
Safeway in the South you've got Kroger
and the other South you've got Publix
what else is there
Albertsons Albertsons okay so when you
go to your grocery store like your major
grocery store you enter in your phone
number to get a discount right what they
do with that is they understand your
buying behavior and they'll show you
they'll send you stuff in the mail or
they will just learn about inventory
whatever and this is incredibly
effective so effective that there's a
famous story about a woman being a
sixteen year old get a woman getting
mailed stuff to her dad's home saying
like baby supplies and the dad was like
right hey my daughter sixteen she's not
pregnant what he talked about
turns out she was pregnant and they knew
it because in your party yeah yeah month
you know what to buy anyway when you go
and buy that ship did you know that you
can submit like a request and they'll
send you all of your do not track
request well that you could do it do not
track and they can send you everything
you've ever bought oh that's pretty cool
okay I like it so what what would you do
with that data
yeah I think that's just an interesting
thing you could do in general like a
mint calm style I think you could say
hey what's your phone number okay then
you go request it on behalf of the
customer and you give them cool
visualizations about their spending
patterns over time and other products
they might like but
I don't what do you would I do with that
data if I was the company or if I was
myself what do you think if you're
trying to build a business I would go
figure out other areas where this sort
of like linking and tracking will work
and so so a lot of people have already
done this right like the ad market it's
kind of like porn where porn innovates
first okay a close second or third might
be the ad market so you know fir Khan
who was kind of my co-founder or CTO of
my previous company his previous company
was an ad tech company and they one of
the versions of their app that they made
so the company is called app lovin and
so initially the premise was what apps
are your friends loving we will
recommend those apps to you and so it
was like if I know what apps you have
and I know that you're my friend because
you're in my address book then it can
tell me that sampar loves this app I
thought it was a play on McLovin no it
was I don't know maybe that was a side
benefit because every love super bad but
won it but then all kinds of little edge
cases started [__] them up so they
would you know record they would tell me
that you love Grindr right like so so
first it's like not everybody's app
behavior they want to be transparent to
their friends or their contacts and I
think there was one really horrible case
where this so then they switched us
trying to do this for app installs so
they're like okay if I'm playing a game
and it's awesome I'm sorry
forget about it's awesome I'm playing a
game and they want you to download that
game because they get paid 9 bucks if
you download the game they would show my
face from your address book as hey
Shaun's playing candy crush right now
tap here to play candy crush - and that
was like a super effective ad unit like
there were like printing money and I
think something really bad happened
we're like the CEO of Expedia or
something like that
got an ad that like his deceased wife
was playing this game or something like
that like someone from his address book
who had this app was shown to him and
he's like what the hell is this and so
it got back to them and they had to turn
it off and they would they they did they
did a similar experiment around location
tracking like have a life 360 thing so
yeah you're really careful with these
like data
oh let's use data to give you
information about either yourself or
others you can get the situation like
the dad who finds out a 16 year olds
pregnant
I long story short privacy okay I have a
privacy idea for you I love a privacy
idea for you so I just think it's just
because I've become like I like the
older I've gotten I've gotten like more
libertarian and like [__] the government
like mentality well there's two things
are happening there's people who bring
on a libertarian which is like eff the
government and if the man in general and
then there's people are becoming more
nationalistic which is like it's us
first them and us first them main sort
of keep them out and raise us up and I
think in both cases you see this sort of
like retreat in both cases it's sort of
it's not like a shelter in place
physically but it's a shelter in place
sort of psychologically behaviorally
where you reduce your like openness and
your spread it you know in your
behaviors and your data in another way
so I think people in general when times
get a little crazy people there's a
flight to safety and I see I think you
see this with investing I think you see
this with the way people act and behave
so I think that more people do it when
they're when times get turbulent now a
privacy focused idea that I had the
other day so moved into this new house
need to get internet set up oh [__]
got to play the Comcast game Comcast
comes over and of course you know Wi-Fi
doesn't really work great in my house so
I was like okay I need to invest in good
Wi-Fi because not having good Wi-Fi is
like not having water to drink and so
I'm like looking for these like Eero
these kind of mesh networks that you use
in your house I just thought one give
you more coverage so I just bought euro
but I was talking to FERC on and I was
like I think euro sucks well I hope it
doesn't slash because I just bought it
but but the idea that I was thinking
about was you know how when you what
typically happens you have your Wi-Fi
router and then on your laptop you'll
have like a VPN so a lot of people have
VPNs VPNs are more and more popular some
people have it for work
some people have it to hide their
traffic as they go bootleg movies on the
internet and they don't want it to be
sort of traced to them and so VPNs are
kind of complicated like to set up like
you got to download one you don't know
if it's malware you're setting it up the
average person doesn't know what the
hell VPN is I was asking I've done a ton
of research on this market well the idea
was actually why don't you build VPN
into the router so you never need it
down
anything it's just VPN by default and
it'll thing into the hardware itself and
so you actually the the value prop of
the router is this is secure Internet
and and so there so he so forgot of
course like you know there's people
doing this and so I can't say I'm the
first to have this idea but he was
telling me about a couple of companies
to check out if you're interested in
this so next DNS is one of them ubiquity
is another one and so he was showing me
a few of these that today are still kind
of like you kind of need to be a
developer to a know about these or be
like know how to configure them to set
them up and so I think if somebody takes
the zero level of simplicity and design
but they make the value prop hey your
your internet search traffic your
whatever you're doing on the Internet is
private if you buy this box instead of
that box I think hard thing behind that
the hard thing about these compass so
first of all the VPN in businesses I did
a I wrote about them because I think
that it's gonna explode and they already
are exploding but a lot of them are
based in Panama because of the privacy
laws there and a lot of them are
notoriously scammy and weird they're
also ridiculously profitable like I
talked to the one guy he had one it made
twenty million dollars a year in revenue
and like a hundred million in profit
like right stupid but euro do you
remember
you know euro got bought by Google I
think Amazon I think Amazon it like God
acquired for nothing these companies are
so hard to make money because it cost so
much money right yeah I think hardware
is hard everybody knows that
like ring doorbell you know it gets a
billion dollar outcome but like I don't
think it was like ultra profitable at
the time I think was strategic the
reason it got bought but the reason I
think Wi-Fi router is interesting
because Wi-Fi is like email it's like
Google search it's a thing that
everybody has every every physical place
has a router and so though two percent
of that market that cares about privacy
I think is still a big market and I
think I don't I don't believe that it's
so hard to make money because again you
like with this Comcast box that I have
here I got to pay these guys fourteen
bucks a month just for this router to
sit here it's no way this router is
worth more than like fifty dollars but
they're gonna make money on me you know
break even in five months and they know
I'm never gonna like get rid of my
router and so so yeah I think that
there's something interesting there yeah
also [__] those guys this episode is
brought to you by what do you got okay
here's something interesting I saw the
other day all right so by the way this
Costco for services that I bear you put
freaking awesome but go ahead yes okay
you wanna do that one let's do that wow
I don't know anything about it
I pray you got a problem I want to hear
but you keep doing what you're doing
then we'll do that one okay all right so
the one I was gonna say is much more
pouring it's so it's about tax so I've
been getting into tax stuff now because
when you get a little bit of money
you're like oh [__] why am i paying so
much tax is there a way I think rich
people avoid this how did they do that I
need to learn their game and so I was
learning about like a what are legal
sort of tax avoidance tax shelter
strategies how do you you know avoid
paying forty eight percent tax which is
what I ended up paying a lot of stuff in
California here and so so one of the
things that I learned about was so
there's solar credits right so Solar is
one of these things that the government
subsidizes so if you have a building you
can buy solar and you can take a hundred
percent of the installation cost as tax
write-off so I was like okay that's cool
but okay where am I gonna put that on my
house I don't know and I don't really
dude solar I'm so ignorant when it comes
to taxes so when you say right off that
just reduces that just increases your
income yeah like let's say you make a
million bucks if you're gonna pay you
know 40 something percent 43 to 48
percent tax here in California cuz it's
let's say it was all ordinary income and
and you're in the highest tax bracket so
you're gonna pay all that in tax now you
know if you're if you have certain
business expenses or personal losses or
tax offsets you can reduce your your
overall tax burden so instead of paying
400 grand in taxes you pay 300 grand
which saves you a hundred grand so you
gotta buy the damn thing you still gotta
buy the damn thing but but if you if you
need a thing or you like with solar so
this is where I'm getting at so
typically with solar it's like oh well I
need power anyways I'll save every month
on my monthly bill and I can get a tax
write-off today so there's a good
investment right I'll take 100 grand
I'll put it in alright
100 grand immediately on my taxes so
it's sort of like I got the thing for
free and then I'm gonna get a lower
utility bill every month after that
right so that's the theory
why don't but you get it for free I kind
of I'm so stupid I don't know I'm gonna
spend an extra hundred grand but
immediately by spending that I can write
off the hundred grand off my taxes so
yes I had to take another hundred grand
out of pocket but now I have to pay a
hundred grand less in taxes right so you
can see how it offsets your tax but no
you don't pay a hug
god we said I think I just I'm so
fearful of something like such a [__]
idiot
I don't Stu I think I don't think you
might could be wrong too but I don't
think you you spend a hundred grand less
in taxes you spend a hundred gram times
forty three percent like no it's like a
hundred grand less it's not let's say my
total tax is if my total taxes do was
four hundred grand and I have a hundred
thousand dollar offset you know a
deduction that I could that I can make
so you take my total tax bill four
hundred thousand and you reduce it by a
hundred thousand so now my total tax
bill is three hundred thousand that's
how it works for sure okay okay so
anyways I know nothing so I've been
trying to find what are these deductions
how do they work do I do I qualify now
interesting market that I saw so my my
father-in-law was like yeah you know
with solar I was like I don't own a
building he's like yeah if you own real
estate you know you can depreciate the
real estate you can do solar as I kind
of owned a building so what do you want
me to do here he's like well you know
technically you could buy the solar for
another building and lease it to them
and then you write off your hole and
your capex whatever and so what I found
was there's this business so if you ever
noticed there's a long way of saying if
you notice when you drive by schools
that schools all have solar panels on
top now and so if you see in California
especially you go every middle school
high school is just got solar panels all
along the roof and the way this works I
found out was companies like Chevron and
Exxon or whoever they want so they want
tax credits and so what they do is they
go to the school say hey we will buy
solar for your school and they buy solar
panels for the school it becomes a tax
write-off to them the school leases it
from Chevron and so Chevron gets a
monthly payment from the school and the
school gets lower utilities without ever
taking a dollar out of its pocket so I
thought this is very interesting and it
sort of
I don't know much about this yet and so
I'm a I'm gonna dig into this but it
seems like there's a there's a business
to be had for basically pairing up
schools churches other types of entities
that want solar they want a lower
utility bill they don't have the money
to invest to do this whole
infrastructure thing and businesses
which are looking for tax write-offs and
just make it where you push a button the
project happens and you receive your
paperwork that says here's your
deduction and here's your income stream
coming from the lease so I think there's
a business to be built basically pairing
up the two sides of the marketplace a
physical building like a school or
whatever that needs that wants solar it
doesn't to pay any money he doesn't to
do any work and a company that's looking
for tax write-offs that that's willing
to go give that school solar in exchange
for the tax write-off love it I'm gonna
tell you something even similar as well
and this is in the same vein of half
very half-baked 10% baked 1% begged most
highway medians and government property
or public property has grass and the
reason it the reason it has grass as
grass is the cheapest way to cover land
okay but grass is actually incredibly
expensive to upkeep like if you're in a
median you have to mow it like the way
that the math works out it's something
like I forget the exact there's there's
math behind this but and then plus
having to mow it and water it and do all
this stuff it's incredibly expensive and
in LA I have to remember the numbers but
in LA I think that like 20 or 30 percent
of all water went to watering lawns
right and so what they did was they
tested this out and they gave turf to
their residents they just gave it away
they go here bull here will do it for
you yeah and it reduced water usage
significant amount and I started
thinking about it I'm like that's kind
of interesting what if you just went to
the government and you're like I'm we're
just gonna let's let's just turf all the
all the medians in America right and I
cuz I heard that NPR they did this whole
this whole this whole thing they like
about how bad grass is and I was like
that's pretty
amazing I got a look into this and I
have not looked into it so this is what
I sound like there's a [__] it this
whole episode but no let me give you one
more okay say here's okay here's the
general theme of these really random ass
topics we're talking about is when you
look around the world and is what I'm
now training my brain to do when you
look around the world and you see some
item or object or patch of grass just
think to yourself how did this get here
and what you realize is there is a
business underneath every single thing
like this is what going back to when we
said you know in offices you got that
poster about like the kind of HR hazards
or whatever like the super stupid labor
law poster you have to come in here I
think it's a huge business that's a
Hellmouth I was blind to this right I
just saw this poster I didn't ask how it
got there I didn't ask why it had to be
there why every office has this but
whoever asked that question realized
there's an opportunity here and they
started laminating these [__] posters
and making 50 million dollars a year
giving you this annual poster that you
have to update in your office so that's
the the test for the for the listener is
start to look at the world and say how
did this get here who wanted this here
what is the economics of this again
oftentimes the that that's a good great
point Sean a lot of times when people
they don't think about that stuff and it
what if you dug deep a lot of times you
could realize that there was some
bureaucratic decision that was a [__]
horrible decision right yeah and there
could be opportunity could be a totally
busted so a lot of times there is like a
scrappy entrepreneur who comes up with
something cool like that sign business
other times it's like well why did you
guys decide to like make the screws 5
inches instead of 6 inches it's like
because like the six on the keyboard was
worn out right right alright so here's
another example of these like hidden in
plain sight businesses all right you go
to a you go to a airport you take a
flight you go to baggage claim ok cool
night nine times out of ten your bags
there now the other ten times out of the
out of 100 or whatever you know your bag
is lost and they recover it but there
still ends up being this point three
percent of luggage that's never claimed
and the number point three so it goes to
ninety-nine point seven percent of
luggage I believe is gets claimed and so
0.3% of luggage is just unclaimed
baggage so I saw this business called
unclaimed baggage what they have done is
they went and they partnered with every
airline and they said - we will take the
unclaimed baggage because they have some
protocol like I don't know what it is
like after 21 days if no one claims it
now we're just stuck with this [__] and
somebody was like hey that is not [__]
that's a suitcase and that's some stuff
inside and yeah so they were like David
seen the 16 minutes episode on this it
was like I'm not serious
Bama Birmingham Alabama I believe you're
play there based somewhere random it's
the yeah they have a physical store in
where's yeah
Alabama Scottsboro Alabama yeah I know
this company well I love it so you can
go to their website Unclaimed Baggage
comm it's there's things as the nation's
only retailer of lost luggage that
caught my eye anytime you say only that
means I locked up an exclusive on this
[__] I'm so happy that I can be the only
player which means I'm gonna extract a
lot of value here so what they do is
they donate a bunch of stuff that they
get into bags to charities cool there's
a feel-good component to this
they take orphaned bags and they recycle
them they sell them or they donate them
and those three combined or a business
and so this was just like to me such a
cool clever idea I couldn't find like
their revenue I didn't have a chance to
check but you can go on the site and
it's like to call again unclaimed
unclaimed bag it's like you'll buy this
there's a Rolling Stones collector's
limited edition leather motorcycle
jacket for five hundred dollars up on up
for auction on this thing what's the
call uncle unclaimed baggage unclaimed
baggage calm well we could find this out
I I remember sixty minutes but it did a
big like expose on the a while ago and
it was like oh uh they they have like
tens of thousands of square French right
yeah they're huge huge facility there
the other one that's like this which i
think is more popular people know about
this more is the group that takes the
okay you go to a hotel you use you know
two squirts of shampoo out of the mini
bottle and now there's still three
squirts left and then you check out and
they can't they don't want to give that
empty half-empty bottle to the next
guess
so they ditch it and so some guy was
like wool that's a lot of waste of
plastic and shampoo and so someone
started going into hotels and partner
and said I will take all your used
shampoo bottles conditioner bottles body
wash whatever and so they built a huge
business just recycling this I love that
they take it they reuse the goods they
donate certain things to charity and
it's such a good business it's like
doing good while doing well and I think
those are great I love that here's why I
just googled so Doyle Owens is the
founder of Unclaimed Baggage he's he's
dead now he died recently and if you
google I'm he's just like an old
Southern right white looking to I mean
just a normal ass looking dude and a guy
who watches Billy Madison three times a
day well the reason why I like him is
because or I like this is because I
think that people tend to overcomplicate
things and like I'm very passionate
about the mission of reducing waste
just like you just don't like the idea
of don't consume what you don't have to
consume it just don't be wasteful I was
raised Catholic I'm like this idea of
like gluttony and like waste it just as
it's in my blood like I hate it this
[__] guy this is like the definition
of just like turn and [__] into goal of
just like right she's just like it's a
super simple it's not fancy it's an
Alabama which you know I'm from the
south so but no disrespect to the south
but like people look down on that [__]
because I think they're in Silicon
Valley that they're special and he's
just that this guy reduced waste
significantly and got very wealthy in
the process right loved it and created
he probably created maybe thousands of
jobs for like low income people this guy
is the best I love this if you have if
you know about a business like this I'll
call the hidden in plain sight you know
super simple ideas just things that when
you look around the world most people
just take them for granted and then
somebody out there's like no wait how
did this get here who picks this up when
it's done what's the business of that
tweet those at me I want to know what
other businesses are like this out there
did you joint did you make a life to get
them do you make that term up
no I think they use that term for like
serial killers that are just in society
so like that's where I've heard it it's
like
criminals in some way but I don't know
yeah it's a phrase do Doyle Owens is
this guy's name who started Unclaimed
Baggage I love this guy
Doyle I hope you listen to this he's
dead sorry I said you know dad I'm
looking at his obituary he's dead damn
this guy is [__] awesome don't no one
go into this market I want this family
to be I love this family three seconds
of silence for Doyle [__] there's a
big New York time this is I got to cover
this on the hustle this is a super
interesting story an example of this
that you guys covered on the hustle is
the mannequin lady in Oakland yeah takes
you know I guess either used or damaged
mannequins out of stores cuz again what
are you gonna do with this hunk of
plastic like who needs this mannequin
and she's just got a warehouse of
mannequins and then ships them out and
makes it killing so so there that's
another example of these Oh like these
are parts of the world that you didn't
realize are businesses all right Aubry
you give us Casco for services what are
you thinking here so this is kind of
like a pin duo dual thing right so yep
shop in bulk you get a discount
so this is a two-part thing so what you
would do is you would go to these
companies SAS companies to say looking
Adobe and say hey what kind of tears
what kind of pricing you know discount
per tier would you offer let's say hey
if I can bring a hundred customers we
can offer 10 percent discount five
percent discount of our normal prices
the second thing would obviously just
you know have a website where people can
kind of create groups and claim that
discount right you can call them pods
clusters let's say you got a 10%
discount for 50 people the website will
show hey 40 people already in this pod
ten more you guys get to clean this
discount yeah what you're describing is
group buying and it could be great a few
companies that do something similar to
this are app sumo stack social I think
does it they're they're good companies I
know and then there's a new one called
um is it called secret or ghost you know
talking about Sean no ghost is like a
blogging platform so I think it's called
secret or something like that anyway
it's called secret I think I'm looking
at them I was gonna partner with them in
some capacity it's an interesting
business model that a lot of people
have tried founder's card is another one
that's like a probably a twelve million
dollar a year business it's it's an
interesting business no one has actually
made this scale wonderfully and I talked
to um I'm gonna name drop a little and
at the backstage of hustla con we had
the founder of we were not the one
that's in the news but the other one
Miguel is his name
and he and what they did with they I
don't remember how many tenants they had
maybe fifty thousand at the time and he
said they launched just like rewards
card where they got group discounts and
he said no one used it and that shocks
me because what you're describing Abreu
I'm like yeah ever you want to save
money of course you're gonna use that
but for some reason people don't do it I
don't know why businesses that have made
this work in an indirect rate way are
RetailMeNot they kind of make it they
made it work a little bit I mean it's
that company sold for like a billion
dollars I think I mean it was a huge
exit or maybe it's still independent but
large business what do you think Sean I
like group buying I have a friend who
taught me a lot about group buying car
he was telling me a lot about group
buying companies everything was
fascinating but I don't retain any of
the I didn't retain any of the
information so we're gonna have to ask
him to come on and explain some of these
group buying companies alright let's
move on to the next one I have some
other interesting things first did you
know Jeff Bezos was adopted yeah by
keeping that keep it dead I don't think
he was adopted as an orphan I think his
like mom remarried you know his dad left
or his parents got split his mom
remarried and as does he have it so
talked to his normal I don't think so
because for Father's Day he posted like
this is my dad and so I don't know
that's like a well I read his bio he
considers his Cuban father which I think
is a step like he's a Cuban guy as his
dad dad his real dad yeah and I just
thought was crazy like imagine adopting
the wealthiest man in the world Steve
Jobs was adopted I too and then he met
his birth father at a restaurant and his
birth father didn't know that that was
oh I didn't know that I am a pianist and
then when he went to the restaurant and
he saw his birth father Steve knew whose
birth father was and the birth father
goes oh my god Steve Jobs is at my
restaurant I cannot
leave this and like flipped out over it
I don't think he Steve ever told him he
was his son that's amazing I didn't I
didn't know about that okay I have
another company that I think is cool I
want to talk about that's it you're just
gonna save Jeff Bezos that's the whole
subject I just thought imagine adopting
someone who became Jeff Bezos that's
crazy okay let me tell you a quick tip
that is a business Companies House
that's the name of it and then there's
the equivalent of Australia did you know
that in Australia in many of the
countries in Europe if you're a
privately held company that's above like
40 million in revenue I think you have
to submit an annual report yes I didn't
know that I went to the Australia's
version and a British I'll show you the
version it cost $5 per port it's called
Companies House for Britain it's
completely free I just like looked up
all these cool companies and you can see
how much like dividends they make right
if my friend started this in in Great
Britain also called due diligence this
is called do deal is his company and I
think it's like a massively last I
checked it was like a massively
successful company and I was like how
are you getting all this private company
data he's like oh it's just like you
have to make it available here so what
we do is we just aggregate it present it
make it searchable and I was like oh my
god like you know Jesus how you know hey
I wish that existed in the US and B what
a simple beautiful business to do I'm
looking at the amazing did you find
anything interesting from these or did
you want to shout them at his cool tool
so what was the one I'm gonna check out
the Australian one it was what house
company house that's Britain it's free I
don't know what it was just easy to use
like am i I know it's not Companies
House is easy to use the Australian one
it's not easy it was called the
Australian AAS I see Australian
Securities and Investment Commission I
guess that's their equivalent of the SEC
right and it cost money so I looked up a
research business that was similar to
mine and I was curious and the founder
just pays himself ten million dollars a
year and it's in there I just looked at
the financials it's pretty big it's
called them you probably notice a BIST
world
yeah yeah yeah it was well I didn't
realize that's how big 100 million so
you don't wanna million idea is and
these might this might exist already but
you can build a layer on top of these
just to make them more user-friendly
searchable it's sort of easy to use
clean up the data in some way and those
can be pretty pretty awesome businesses
import genius is a great example of this
you know publicly available customs data
that they make a it's not even that easy
to use but they make an interface that
makes it very sort of simple and easy to
find the data that you're looking for
and so you know if there's some
entrepreneur in Australia who wants to
take ASIC and make it more of a consumer
facing website or maybe that exists but
that would be a cool opportunity what
else so I saw this company I liked
called a line I almost hesitate to even
talk about it cuz I'm like very
interested in it may invest may use it
may like the teeth thing not the teeth
thing it's it's pretty cool so you know
how lambda school sort of popularized
income share agreements they you know
basically I train you you go get a job
you have to pay me back out of that sort
of like a novel way of doing student
debt so income share agreements are
getting more popular as lambda school
has sort of proven that they work so all
the lambda school clones I don't think
they've proven they've worked I think
that they're proven that some people are
interested in them and what income share
agreements yeah
I'm critical of them yeah I don't really
know why you would be critical and why
are you critical first of all I don't I
think that the bootcamp idea is just
unrealistic okay but that's different
that's not as different I don't know I
I'm not well-versed on it yet so I don't
my opinion is I'm skeptical which is
okay here's what I think is in that
here's what I think is a very valid
skepticism of it hey you're making a
you're making this sound like a totally
new thing this is just a different form
of student debt like I go to school and
then when I graduate I have to pay back
X dollars for my education
that's student debt that's how an income
share agreement works and that's also
how student debt works so
a lot of people who are like uh you know
student debt evil student debt big
problem in the country income share
agreements novel disruption and really
they're both just debt instruments that
work it has that different I didn't have
student debt luckily but but you know I
friends who are still sort of you know
paying that off and so so anyways I
think that's the valid
that's the valid criticism which is this
is not that different the income share
is not that different you know the one
difference would be with student debt
you owe it regardless of whether you get
a good job or not for income share
agreement you only owe it if you get a
high paying job so the incentive is kind
of a line for the school to train you up
and help you get a good-paying job which
is your goal as well as a student so I
think that's a that's a fair counter but
but anyways my point is it gives your
agreements whether you like them or not
they are getting more popular they've
sort of worked non-existent five to ten
years ago and now they're getting more
popular and it's a financing instrument
and so what a line is doing I think the
websites hello align calm they basically
made like sort of a stripe for income
treatments so it's just a way for
anybody who wants to set up an income
share agreement to do so with like sort
of one line of code type of thing they
take care of the whole income share
agreement process so let's say I which
is true I have ideas for new education
models new schools new ways to teach
people and help them earn more money I
could now shut up and set up an income
share agreement website like without
having to do any of the sort of Finance
you know compliance like all that work
that I would normally need to pay a
bunch of lawyers and spend a bunch of
time doing now I just get it out of the
box so it's like when Twilio made SMS
you know an easy thing to use out of the
box or talk box made it easy to use
video streaming or stripe made it easy
to credit card processing now these guys
did it for income share agreements which
i think is a very clever niche how big
are they what's the attraction any brand
new i think they're an early access
right now i'm on board with that i don't
think i would invest because i'm not
investing in i don't want to invest in
private companies right now because i
have i'm just a [__] but I'm just
[__] fearful at the moment I've been
the stock I'd rather be the stock market
but
that's cool I would put I would I would
put I would I liked it enough that I
would be close to putting my money where
my mouth is on it right I don't think I
would invest either but I just think
it's cool that somebody built this and
also I think it's a good example of
identify nice trend a lot of people do
this when BOTS started getting more
popular they're like cool here's a bot
maker or voice you know echo gets echo
gets big and people start buying a bunch
of Amazon echoes and then people made it
easy to make voice apps using things
like voice flow I think you want to be
on the edge where is this a trend if it
is a trend I can spin up the super
simple website the more service like you
know oh maybe email marketing is gonna
be a big let me build a really easy way
to email a mass list and track the opens
and whatnot and sure eight times out of
ten that trend is is gonna be is gonna
fizzle out or end up being much smaller
than you think
but being early really matters in these
spaces and so I think that's cool here's
another niche thing that I thought was
cool it's something called agent fire so
this is a website for a real estate
agent it's like a Wix or a Squarespace
specifically for real estate agents so
it's like push a button here's a real
estate agent website this company is
doing a hundred thousand dollars a month
and what's interesting is that there's a
guy you should follow his twitter handle
is vin rob VI n RB and it's guy Robin
Vander Heiden and what he's doing is he
is I don't know I've met the guy yet but
his claim is I help people productize
their service so here's what happened he
request oh my god somebody was making a
service to do this for agents like you
pay me X dollars I'll build you an agent
website and what he helps them do is
turn that into just a specific
standalone SAS product they'll just let
an agent do it automatically so now
there's no human service in the loop and
he hosts a bunch of he tweets out a
bunch of examples of profitable niche
services that have turned into products
and so I thought this is kind of a
goldmine of like cool little ideas and
hacks an agent fire which is the one
which is one of these which is a guy who
was doing this as a service turn it into
a product now doing this is amazing
whose many requests like I mean you said
who he is Rob is this guy raising money
I don't know he's based out of Singapore
everything about this
I'm interested I'd like to ask guy I
think people should follow him because
he's tweeting out gold and he's only got
you know two thousand followers so most
people aren't looking I love Rob I'm
following him now
alright let me wrap it up at the one
thought yeah we've talked about we've
had a bunch of people on here or
investors and we had a friend is raising
a fund right now you know I think I've
changed my mind I think that investing
is [__] stupid
I would have bet a thousand dollars
you're gonna say stupid I would have
been wrong cuz he's so [__] stupid
but like why is investing stupid I would
love to hear why investing is stupid
tell me if I am being like just a baby
here in like but it's just like I just
find this like financial arbitrage [__]
to be so boring and like meaningless
okay and I watch the TV show billions
and I'm like oh that's cool like they're
doing all those big things it looks
exciting and then I'm like well those
guys are losers like they're not
actually adding to I mean they're just
they're wealthy and they're
accomplishing dreams so I respect it but
I also I'm like oh my god that's so
soulless and that's what I think like a
lot of like I've got friends that create
these websites that like they're already
wealthy and they're building these
websites that are like they're just
hawking [__] and they will admit that
they are I'm like the [__] the point
of this and that's kind of what a lot of
investing is but the friends Hawking
[__] that's different than investing
right that's just like selling some
degree for money right it's fun it's
it's definitely from a similar yeah it's
just like why like I like if you're
already can if you already have a little
bit of cash which if you're still trying
to get your hair you know go go you got
to go for it but if you already got a
little bit of cash like do something
cool and meaning so ok so here's here's
I'll give you two to thoughts on this
okay the first is an example that
supports your case and then I'll give
you the feel good reason why you're
wrong so the support your case so I
mentor this guy who's 20 years old
and he's at this point where like he
tried to do some stuff I kind of didn't
work out and now he's like [__] do I
need to go get a job I need to pay my
bills I don't want to go move back home
with my parents and so he's like he's
like about to take this job and he's
like should I you know leave this
entrepreneurial path and go get a job
because I you know I need to pay bills
in two months and I don't think I can
spin something up in the next 60 days
that will get so profitable that I'll be
I know I'll be able to pay my rent and I
said you know I empathize with the
problem but I said you know let's just
slow down for a sec before you go take
that consulting job let's just let's
just talk things through for a second so
I said how much money do you need to
live every month what's your burn rate
two grand two grand fantastic and I was
like so let's say you wanted a year of
runway to go try some [__] you need to
come up with 12 months times 2 grand you
need to come up with 24 grand I said I
know you do some investing in the stock
market you're kind of a degenerate you
know you like to pick stocks attractive
like Bitcoin and [__] I was like because
at the beginning of the conversation
he's like you know am I good the thing
that's going well is my investments I've
done well the things going bad is about
to have to take this job for my my bills
oh hey well those two things don't add
up I was like I was like do you have
enough money in the stock market right
now that you could just sell and you
could use to live off of to chase your
entrepreneurial dreams he's like yeah I
could but then I'd have to sell and I
don't want to sell cuz I'm getting you
know good returns I said okay let's do
the math real quick what do you think
you could generate per let's take just a
twenty four thousand that you need I
don't know how much money you have you
don't have to tell me let's take the
twenty four thousand that you need how
much do you think you generate per year
in return average he's like fifty
percent I was like ok Minnie Warren
Buffett you think you can do 50 percent
a year but let's let's assume you're
delusional number is correct and that
you could do it consistently which is
the hard part you could do it for one
year for sure but consistently generate
50 percent so let's say you you do the
Warren Buffett you you invest perfectly
you get your 50% way above market return
and you're 24 grand has turned into 36
grand now like fantastic congratulations
you made $12,000 like you are still
nowhere near where you're trying to get
with your goals and if you and how many
years would you have to continue to get
this absurd return for you to be with
where your goals
I was like not that many but that would
never happen you would never happen
right you never get the 50% so anyways I
was like you're talking about this year
going and trading all your time for
money at a consulting gig when instead
you could just sell some of your stock
get 24 grand of runway and you could
live for 12 months and give yourself a
bunch of shots on goal to try to build
something that you believe in and you'll
learn way more you'll have way more fun
and you'll have way more upside than if
you go take the consulting job so like
you're crazy so he was of the mindset of
well I heard that rich people invest so
I want to invest and I want to get
return I want my money to work for money
he had kind of heard all these things
and was in was investing for that reason
so I think investing doesn't make sense
when you have very little amount of
capital overall and you're trying to go
invest that capital and then you're
trading your time for $4 in other ways
now the other so that's the argument for
times when I think investing would be
stupid is when you know if you take a
normal return the amount of money that
you're making every month is not every
year is not gonna change your life and
you're locking up money in the stable
what's the second point cuz I think the
second point have to be better than the
first point the first point that you
made was that well only of us if you got
a lot yeah exactly if you if you don't
have a lot I'd rather you use that money
if you're entrepreneurial if you're one
of the five 5% of people who actually
want to build a business or do something
on their own
you're better served investing in
yourself and investing in buying your
time back yeah and and and going taking
about shot uncle now the second is is
investing stupid well I think you're
kind of right that it is not the most
exciting thing but excitement is
different for everybody but here's the
cool way of thinking about investing
like for anything to work you need
leverage right so you were on the hustle
but day to day you write zero emails
probably you don't write the daily email
you don't do the trends report this
podcast is the most active thing you do
for the Hustle is that correct it we
could say yes for a sake of argument
okay so first sake of argument your
argument is correct I'm leverage so
you're leverage because you got a bunch
of humans doing work for you cool
another form of leverage is media so
we're gonna talk for one hour and this
is gonna get listened to for hundreds of
thousands of hours out there so media is
another form of leverage and then the
last one is capital capital is another
form of leverage and so here's the cool
way of thinking about it which is if you
have capital investing is your way of
allocating capital to things that are
either a gonna return the most or big
and I like change the world in a way
that you care about and so capital is
your way of influencing the way that the
world goes because you get to assign
units of energy to different companies
and causes that are that are gonna go do
do do I get that I think that's a great
point I think that what I'm completely
burnt out of it's just lame-ass
investments what's a lame-ass investment
like you don't have to use a name if you
want to kind of code name something like
I've got a friend that gave a lot of
money to some like an investor who's
gonna buy a bunch of multifamily real
estate and it's simply a like I've don't
ever see this I don't touch it like this
is a 7% this is simply an asset class
and it's just a thing on a spreadsheet
and I'm like oh my god that's so boring
like but like I just I can't decide if
I'm being a little like [__] hater or
yeah but my or like when I have we have
some friends who are buying companies
and they just look for anything that
like checks the boxes of does net churn
this and is the acquisition cost this
and that's it that's all I mean like
mechanical yeah yeah and I get it and
I'm like all right that's great way to
make money but it's just like so [__]
lame sometimes I'm like oh my god you
guys like can you like can we please do
something exciting
so okay so here's the here's the rub
okay let's say you don't invest you're
gonna either a park cash and on the side
and do nothing with it probably lamer
than investing in it and having the cash
grow or be you're gonna what's the
what's door number see so what else
would you what a what would you prefer
to do with your capital besides invest
or leave it in cash either start calm
and even if that means I don't run them
or that's investing yeah I'm not saying
investing I'm using I'm using investing
because I can't think of a better word
no investing is cool
I mean investing is great but I'm just
saying like arbitrage is again starting
a company is arbitrage but I think you
understand what I'm saying yeah I get
where you coming from
I don't know I I just I just hit me last
week where I'm like oh my god this is I
don't want to talk about a carry fee
ever again or I go like this is just so
[__] lame when like you see like like
I think it happened when I was traveling
I'm like I just see these normal ask
people at the gas station and they're
with their wives and kids and like
they'd like I would I'm Way more
fascinated about how do I just make that
person just a little bit happier or a
little bit better not like how do I eat
out a little more profit out of this
service do the same like it's like I saw
these I remember be at this gas station
and I saw this mom give her kid like a
like a generic coke and I was like like
help this mother like Oh either afford
or learn that this thing or that thing
is now is like how can we help her make
a better decision maybe better decision
easy not how do I get a 5 per second I
think I actually understand what you're
saying now which is it's not that
investing is stupid it's not that
putting money in someplace and getting a
return is stupid what you are starting
to get annoyed of or or tired of is the
amount of the amount of your mental
energy that goes towards thinking about
how to reproduce a where do you devote
mental energy and not we're just money
go it's kind of like I get that money
you gotta do something with the money
might as well put in a place that's
gonna grow might as well fund a company
that's gonna do something but it's about
mentally spending cycles thinking about
how do I get 7% verse 8% versa tax
efficient 9% versus just mentally
spending those same cycles thinking
about something else if I kept reading a
book talking to a person building
something cool writing a song whatever
it's gonna be is that is that more
accurate yeah
like get out of this financial arbitrage
circle-jerk and actually make a
difference and have an exciting
wonderful life yeah
both myself and others I'm with you on
that I'm with you on that I catch myself
doing that all the time where I'm like
how many hours is my brain spending on
you know in this financial game
and there's some so amount that's
correct but it's very easy to slip into
more than more than what you need more
than what's adding value I love that TV
show billions and I'm like oh man like
Bobby ox raw rod this powerful
billionaire guy he's going to war versus
other people that's [__] awesome I
love that yeah he's an alpha and then
I'm like but he's also just a jerk-off
who's just trying to like squeeze
pennies out of this thing of that thing
and it's complete nonsense right you
know what I mean
yeah I think you know I think what also
happens is important which is in your
20s you're trying to figure out what you
like twenties in many ways about feeding
ego it's like whether you're partying
trying to make friends trying to date
people trying to you know get your get
your name on the map in you know your
career or your industry I feel like a
lot of people including myself their
twenties are spent feeding the ego and
then your 30s are spent figuring out
that okay my ego is either full or it
will never be full and I actually want
to feed the soul in some kind of way
actually want to be more conscious of
how I spend my time and my energy and
and then there's this constant push and
pull of like maybe I just want to make a
bunch of money like maybe I'm not
ambitious enough well I think you can
over money focus and there's like these
debates that I have my head I sounds
like you do too I think you could do
both and I think that I guess the point
is I'm beginning to realize I love the
builders more than the alligators like
yeah yeah yeah exhibit fucking-a
builders over alligators all day okay
yeah good that's a good that's a good
way to end the podcast I put if you if
you listen to us meander through that
last five minutes hopefully either with
some value in the end
[Music]